this is a production of cornell
university
um thank you for that and thank you
carlin for inviting me here this is an
exciting place for me to be because i do
work with a lot of
horticultural crops
so i'll get started by kind of laying
out what i want to talk about today um i
kind of have like
three big like introductory buckets that
i think are really important before we
get to what breeding insight is doing so
i want to talk first about the grand
challenges and blockers that breeders
feel in general but specifically
horticultural breeders
and then i'd like to talk a little bit
about the types of breeding programs we
encounter in our in our work
and then i want to lay a foundation for
how germplasm banks can really or should
really be leveraging reading programs
today and then we'll end on what we're
actually doing at breeding insight and a
new initiative called bi onramp
so well first of the grand challenge
really is adapting to climate change and
this is the elephant in the room for me
because it is a huge issue it's
extremely complex
and
it's not something you can do in one
talk or even one slide so i'm gonna do
just start start with an example that
many people probably feel familiar with
and that's uh the plant hardiness zones
so
in 2000 the area of new york that we're
in right now was solidly in his own five
ten years later it was split between a
five and a six
and by 2040
it's going to be completely in a six
so within your lifetime these hardiness
zones have shifted significantly
and climate change isn't just about the
hardiness though
we need to make sure that our breeders
are equipped to breed for varieties that
can tolerate longer growing seasons
flooding and or drought sometimes within
the same location
day and night temperatures
new diseases and pests that are coming
up from the south
and also more weed pressure
the second grand challenge is improving
product quality and storage and this is
really important in crops that are sold
fresh as produce
because they need to improve the post
harvest quality before they're sold at
market
so in apples and potatoes
the amount of marketable yield is
impacted by how much bruising is
sustained before these products are
actually sold
so in this example the uh bruising has
been reduced in both apple and potato
through a transgene
compared to the uh
cultivated non-transgenic uh parental
variety here
so if we can reduce bruising we're gonna
reduce waste and loss
and that will increase our shelf life
and also increase the marketable yield
which is what the farmer's actually
getting paid for
we also need to be considering breeding
for improved nutritional content
so
take for example vitamin a
all the best plant-based sources for
that are all horticultural crops
another thing we need to be thinking
about is labor costs horticultural crops
are really defined by how much labor
they take and are you know
typically thought of as extremely
labor-intensive
and that often can make a breeder or a
grower turn away from using or growing
specialty species because of that
expense and time
but
robotics as shown in this example with
lettuce here
our
new varieties are coming up all the time
from breeders as they start to adapt
their varieties to machine harvesting or
mechanical manipulation
and they're also creating varieties that
are better suited to mass harvest
horticultural crops especially
anything that's eaten as fresh produce
are particularly vulnerable to pests
diseases and weed pressure
so we as a grower or a breeder we want
to minimize profit loss due to cosmetic
defects and spotting and that means that
we end up using a lot of herbicides and
pesticides on our crops and that takes a
toll not only on the the individual
plants themselves but on our environment
so by increasing
the ability of a crop excuse me the
crop's ability to resist pests and
diseases and uncomplete weeds on its own
means we can apply less uh herbicides or
pesticides and have a lower impact on
the environment we're living in
and lastly we all rely on a global food
supply chain to get food from farms to
supermarkets to our homes and at the
best of time you probably never even
think about this but if this pandemic
has probably shown you anything
is that our food supply chain is
extremely fragile
and disruption of that food supply chain
disproportionately affects populations
that are already at risk for poverty and
hunger and is this uh article from last
month stated an additional 137 million
people face food insecurity as 2020
ended due to the pandemic and two of the
biggest reasons was the interrupted food
supply chain and rising food costs
so how would plant breeders work to
address these brand challenges well they
really got to start on something smaller
so a breeder's goal is to release put
your new trade of interest here
varieties sooner
and
those goals around creating newer better
varieties for release
they may even overlap each other you may
be working on several different uh
objectives in your breeding program
so it may be no chill blueberry
or powdery mildew resistant grape
high bricks melons
longer shelf life or higher yielding
so in major crops there are a lot of
tools and technologies that work across
hundreds of different breeding programs
and that technology has mostly come out
of private research and also
universities
and major crops have a lot in common
with each other
most of them are or all of them are
fully mechanized with low labor costs
they're annual crops that function as
diploids
they are propagated through seed and
have a lot of commercial breeding
support behind it
and they're typically giving high yields
and a dry harvest so products are not
being consumed as harvested
and the
if we look at horticulture crops it's
much different so we'll take an example
above here of tomato and below of grape
and if we think about how many of these
boxes we can tick we can only take a
subset of them so they're both annual
crops that are functional diploids and
can be propagated through seed and there
is some commercial breeding that
supports it but if you work in a species
that's not one of these how many boxes
can you actually take off
and that's important because
tech transfer by trickle-down agronomics
is not going to work for horticultural
crops the number and the diversity of
crops and the diversity of challenges is
too disparate for one solution to fit
and we talk a little bit about
all breeders have challenges but let's
talk specifically about what additional
challenges horticultural breeders may be
feeling
so our breeder goal is to get to newer
and better varieties faster what's
preventing that from happening
well in the logistical category you're
often dealing with small budgets
typically two hundred thousand uh
dollars annually or less
you're often working with a small or
temporary workforce uh breeders are
retiring at a high rate right now uh and
it's labor intensive management um
there's aging facilities and uh ip and
mta restrictions uh
actually makes it much more difficult
for breeders to share even from
different universities
there's also technical blockers
um there may be historical program data
for 50 years
in a breeding program but most of it
isn't digitized so it's not accessible
to the breeder to use
and it's also very difficult if you have
a very small program to adopt new
technologies where do you start and how
do you know what technology is really
going to be long lasting and effective
in your program and how much is it going
to cost to maintain that
environment we talked a little bit about
all of the challenges but if you're a
horticultural breeder
how do you make decisions today for the
environment five to ten years from now
when we've just seen it's changing so
rapidly we're almost at a point where we
cannot predict it
and
what decisions or what data do you need
to make that decision
and lastly biological a lot of our
horticultural crops have complex genomes
or are high polyploid some of them are
are
non-annual life cycles so biennial or
perennial may have self-incompatibility
may have long time to flow long juvenile
periods that require you know 10 years
to get to flowering
so this affects all of these together
can hold a program back and in many
cases needlessly
so next i want to talk briefly about the
types of breeding programs that we see
and before i get into that i want to
talk about the breeder's eye
this is really important because today
most of the progress done in breeding no
matter what species you've looked at
was done through phenotypic selection
and that's true for dogs as much as it
is for corn or tomatoes and the reason
why is it's really easy you can do it in
your backyard you don't need any
specialized equipment
but what what is really difficult is
that it takes years to perfect you can
do it but to be a really good phenotypic
selection breeder it takes 20 to 25
years to really know your germplasm well
enough to do this
so
for most holistic cultural crops breeder
knowledge is really much more important
than
the genetics in their decision making
process
so they're they're looking at the
overall architecture of the plant and
the products coming off the plant and
they're making uh
decisions based on their own evaluation
so relies on high numbers and subjective
evaluations
the next step up would be market
assisted selection where breeders
knowledge is being supplemented with
some genetic information
and this requires that you have some
understanding of the markers associated
with the trait of interest and it's
usually used for disease resistance loci
or other things of mendelian
control
and then the pinnacle of the mountain
really is genomic selection where the
breeder's knowledge isn't nearly as
important as what the genetics can
predict
can be possible
so in this case you're using high
quality phenotype data lots of genotypic
data on your individuals and you're
making selection decisions before you
can even see your phoenix expressed in
those plants and this is likely to be a
really huge benefit for crops that have
a very long generation time because if
you can do speed breeding and
progress your
your generations forward faster than you
can phenotype them you can make more
progress more quickly
and while it looks really simple the way
i've laid it out here
there are real challenges and barriers
to entry that keep readers from moving
up this mountain
and that could be the culmination of all
the logistical technical biological
challenges and that really can hold a
program back and make them feel like
there's no way i can get to this point
and a lot of our phenotypic breeders ask
me why do i need genomics why should i
do this
so my answer to them is that sequencing
technology is accessible and affordable
for all species
you have a lot of information to collect
and assimilate and act upon in short
windows of time and you've got fixed
constraints you don't have infinite
money or time
and you don't get to see if you were
right until it's too late to change
course
so by supplementing their eye with
genomic data and analytics and
prediction models we can start freeing
breeders from some of this grunt work
and reduce the uncertainty in their
programs
so they can get back to doing more
breeding
so this is the the last part of my
introduction i really want to kind of
focus a little bit about the important
role that our germplasm banks should be
playing in our breeding programs
so
our gene banks are places where we keep
our public elites our obsolete cultivars
land races and crop wild relatives and
it's a public resource and anybody can
request infra seeds or
cuttings from the germplasm bank whether
you're a breeder at a university or not
and we also know that the breeder's goal
is to really
release new and improved cultivars and
varieties
but if you stay within your breeding
program and you never
keep a closed system you're really
reducing the amount of new traits and
alleles you can be bringing into your
program that maybe
the insurance you need to be combating
future
challenges is coming up whether it's
climate change or new pests
so the way this happens is that through
the process of discovery breeding or
also called pre-breeding
is taking materials that are unadapted
or more wild and eventually introducing
them in using those native traits in the
breeding program
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
the original library model of germplasm
banks so this is the 80 white library at
cornell it's a classic library it's
gorgeous looking it's very old-fashioned
harry potter-ish you know um and so what
we typically think of is like the
pinnacle of our library right even
though there's probably not any digital
stuff in here at all
um and then we have the cement active
maze germplasm collection and the former
curator is sitting right in the audience
today
so um
she gave a great uh example of how
they're
making some changes at summit and doing
some new research but that's getting a
little bit ahead of myself but the
original model
is to safely and securely store
resources in perpetuity
repair and replace or in the case of
accessions regenerate the resource units
house rare materials and expose the
contents they're in for improved public
access right that's pretty simple i
think everybody would kind of agree that
that's the function of these libraries
and in the us we're very lucky to have
the usda mpgs system
and it's a series of of different kinds
of germplasm banks that are
sometimes seed banks or in the case of
animals it's actually cryo storage
tissue culture banks and living
repository repositories such as up in
geneva the apple and the grape
collections there
globally
you can access even more
accessions and divide diverse materials
if you're going through green global
and this is all free to be distributed
so when we think about how we've gotten
to this point where we're having to go
back to our germplasm banks it's
important to remember that humans have
migrated all over the planet and we take
what we like with us
okay
and that has created a bunch of
different bottlenecks and germplasm
sharing across the across the globe
and so coming back to this very famous
diagram from tanksley mccooch in science
1997
we've basically recapitulated this
process over and over and over again for
all of the species that we breed for
and this is borne out in the molecular
evidence and i'm just going to give two
examples the first is a tomato uh it's
about 2000 snips all of the cultivated
tomatoes are in this band here on this
pca or mds plot and you can see that
there's some
pluses i think they're pluses or x's
um so there's some other accessions that
show in the total diversity of crossable
species
the cultivated tomato is occupying a
very narrow slice of that diversity
and the same is true for upland cotton
or uh cypium hirsutium and so here's the
uh improved varieties in the diamond
shape here and then the wild person the
land raises is all in this screen
so there's a lot of diversity out there
and i will be the first to admit not all
of it is stuff you want in your
domesticated miles
but there's a lot of stuff that we've
gotten rid of because phenotypic
selection is like taking a chainsaw to
the turkey it's not precise it is taking
out large swaths of your genome okay
so i revisited this paper in preparation
for this talk
and i kind of wanted to re evaluate our
underutilized genetic resources and as i
was going through the paper again
which i read as a graduate student
i pulled out a couple of quotes that i
thought
i'd share with you today the first is
the tools of genome research may finally
unleash the genetic potential of our
wild and cultivated germplasm
and then the second is until now
remember this is 1997 we have been only
modestly successful in utilizing these
resources for plant improvement
but that's still true today and why is
that why are we not doing a better job
at
tapping our genetic resources in those
germplasm banks for benefit in our
breeding programs
well
it's not easy right we all kind of
understand this
if you have a germplasm bank and you've
got a native trait of interest that
you're looking to capture
and let's say it's a
few genes major effects or it's a
menelian trait
marker assisted backross or mars or mars
approach has been actually pretty
successful in capturing those traits and
bringing them into elite cultivars
however most of the traits we care about
are quantitative they don't fall into
this mendelian pattern they have many
genes small effects
and that means that this marker assisted
back cross or mars
migration into elite material
it just isn't effective it's just too
slow even though it's cheap to do it's
too slow and it's not effective and it's
it's really caused a lot of heartbreak
and very few success stories
the next is
um
the
the time and effort it takes to do
pre-breeding has to be
an effort that you put forward for that
exact purpose and the way i mean that is
that most mid to large size agricultural
seed companies employ discovery breeders
or pre-breeders in their program
and they do not produce varieties they
produce much different output
their job is to identify desirable new
traits from exotic germplasm
introgress desirable traits into
germplasm using markers
adapt material to the local environment
sometimes it's an elite that just
doesn't work as well in the environment
that they're in
and broaden and maintain genetic
diversity within their institutions
program
so
pre-breeders are actually producing new
parents that then go into line variety
cultivar breeder
programs
and one of the ways they do this is that
they have the money and the time to do
genomic selection plus bridging
so they're able to use markers and that
they are testing on wild material do
crosses within wild material to try to
stack large quantities of alleles and
then use a an elite that can bridge into
the program and by the time you get here
the donor is only at one quarter
percentage of the genome
and then it can enter into a breeding
cycle from the breeder but by then a lot
of the big things of
adaptability flowering time uh plant
architecture have been weeded out no pun
intended uh weeded out of the um the
entering lines from bridging
so when i think about what do we do to
try to assess pre-breeding needs right
now
and green global is a great place to
start because as as a minimal need if
you were a breeder and you wanted to tap
into your genomic
germplasm resources for doing some
pre-breeding
you need to be able to search that gene
germplasm and get lots of different
kinds of data the passport data genetic
data if there's maps that would be great
phenotypic qtl data plant
characteristics photographs published
results and how do i order the seed
right
and it's not enough just to have that
you need to export this you need to
bring all this information into your
program for providence and for
correcting any errors that you might
find if the seedling's messed up
and green global's already doing a great
job with most of this stuff
and these other two the genetic data
including maps and phenotypic qtl data
is already in discussion on how they're
going to build in support and space in
green global for these types of
activities
so my last slide on this section is
really asking you a question is it time
for an updated gene bank model
in 2003 uh 13 the pew research study
asked people about their brick and
mortar libraries what do you want from
your brick and mortar libraries
well everybody wanted everything that
was in the old model
plus they wanted a bunch of new stuff
that was not anticipated
so my question to you is what new
resources or services would you ask of
your species germplasm bank what new
mandates or roles should they be playing
in the propagation and migration of
native traits into breeding programs
okay
that's it for the intro um now we'll get
into some fun stuff talking about
breeding insight and also uh bi online
and as jean-luc mentioned
our goal at breeding insight really is
to transform breeding by enabling the
implementation of genomic insight and
selection
as part of routine breeding specialty
breeding programs all across the usda
ars system
so as a breeder i need to make progress
in my program and there's a couple of
things i really need i need to be able
to manage my program i need to know
who's doing what work in my program what
locations they're in what traits i have
um you know i need to be able to keep
all my data in a central location that's
not excel
i need to be able to go out to the field
and collect data
i need to make sure that data gets back
into my program safely and securely
and then i'm going to manage my samples
some samples are going for dna
extraction others might be going for
express berry testing
and i want access to my germplasm banks
i know this is where i'm going to get my
new alleles for disease resistance i
need to get access to that
and i need to store and collect my
genetic data and put it someplace where
i can find it easily
and then i need to bring my data
together to run genomic analysis
and i got to make decisions so i want
something that helps me make those
decisions and then helps me write my
annual report when i don't want to have
to re-say the same thing each time
i want to be able to generate that
so all breeders are operating on a
12-month calendar cycle it's the nature
of our work um it's also the nature of
the species that live in our environment
and they all need
um about the same things and maybe the
timing is different but they need it in
about the same order so every breeding
program is managing stocks and pedigrees
performing crosses designing and
managing trials and then managing
nurseries or wherever else they're
growing these
they also need to determine their
genotypes
capture phenotypes that might be on pen
and paper could be with a voice recorder
or a tablet
they need to evaluate both their
genotypes and their phenotypes
and then they got to make their
decisions so it could be selection but
it also could be culling decisions as
well
and make the reports and so this is the
digital ecosystem where a breeder is
living these are all these the the
action points that they have to create
every year within their program again
and
again and
we're at the center here trying to
create a unified platform our unified
digital ecosystem where our breeders can
operate and make all of their decisions
in a central location
and while i'm showing this for plants it
doesn't look that different for animals
at least in terms of aquaculture or even
in the terms of bumblebee
basically the same processes
so this allows us to build
economy of scale by generalizing
everything we can and only putting the
species specific uh needs at the end of
our uh program development
okay so i've convinced you you need
software are you gonna start you got a
lot of options here some of them are no
cost some of them are low cost but how
do you know where to start how do you
know what's right for you on this board
given your species
and this is one of the reasons that
breeding insight was created
so
right now we work with six uh ars
specialty groups i'm gonna ignore
the
non-horticultural crops for today and
the non and on the animals as well
and we work with them really closely as
a partner in their program and we help
them we build their genotyping platforms
and find them their providers we help
them manage their phenotypic data and
adopt new tools like fieldbook
and we act as a breeding consultation
and support system when they have a
problem with field book they know who to
call they call us and we have to fix it
and we deliver software considering
what's publicly available in the in the
market right now
what functionality are breeders need to
address their breeder's specified use
cases if you're working in a perennial
you might need to be able to manage your
root stocks not necessary in a fish
program
and we also need to make sure that
anything that we're connecting has a
communication pipeline behind it it can
talk from one program to another and
we'll talk about a little bit more about
how we do that in coming slides
and then we lay on top of that the
species specific
user interface that's intuitive for
breeders
so our initial platform starts with a
breeding management program called breed
base and this was developed by lucas
mueller's group up at bti
and we're also working with the
fieldbook app from the phenol app suite
we're looking at using gigwa for our
genetic data management
and eventually we want to hook up with
green global
and the way we're making uh the
different pieces of software which all
have their own development groups they
all have their own uh objectives
we're connecting them using
um what's called braby which is the
reading api and if you're not familiar
i'm just going to spend like a half a
minute talking about it
brappy is short for breeding application
programming interface and it's just a
protocol for getting different software
to talk to each other quickly and make
sure they speak the same language and as
a user you should never have to see it
or know anything specific about it the
best things are ones you don't have to
think about
but before brappy if someone was using
breed base and field book they'd have to
export files out of breed base then
import it into the tablet for fieldbook
then take the data send it back out put
it back in
that's four steps where a human has to
be interacting okay
but if you're using brappy
you're basically having database talk to
database and so it's under the covers
it's not seen and it's nothing the user
really has to worry about
and there's um so in terms of
integrating the software the first
integration we worked on is getting
breed base and field book to connect to
each other through grappy without
needing the manual file transfer and
it's fairly simple you can load a field
directly from freebase onto the tablet
you can then go out and collect your
phenotypes
and then when you export it back to
breed base you get a summary of what
you've exported
so you get a little bit of a
qc step there that tells you you know
you got through this many evaluations
today
and anybody's welcome to use that um and
it's available in the current field book
and all the way back to 4.1
so
in terms of breed base it has a lot of
functionality but our breeders find it
very difficult to navigate it's the
interface is not intuitive for them and
it's not really set up for a breeding
program's 12-month calendar cycle
so we're using a workflow-based approach
to lower that barrier to entry and
improve the user experience while
you know basically taking advantage of
all of the great breed-based
functionality below
so i have a couple of screenshots to
show you of our software
for our treat management
you can
look at your traits and get a trait
details right in a pop-up window
you can add new traits very simply here
so if you want to test out a new trait
for you know a new
you know you're seeing rust come up in
your population you want to give a
do a couple different ways of testing
that to see which is heritable you can
set that up right here
you can also manage your program your
locations which locations are have which
trials
manage your users ad users
and then get clear notification when
things are have been completed and made
changes to the database
and rather than asking people to put all
of their data into a template that the
computer can understand we're asking the
computer to understand what the data is
and so in this case you have your output
file from
whatever phenotypic data you have
you create a mapping using the brappy
fields
and then you just import your file
directly you do not need to convert your
file to an importable format the
computer will do that for you
so the nice thing about using brappy as
our standard and as our data model is
that it gives us a lot of flexibility
because breed base is brappy compliant
and so is pheno apps and gigwa and bring
global's on its way to being compliant
so that means if we have a new breeder
comes in and they work on peach and they
say but i use the gdr i use the genome
database for rosacea i don't want to
change my database model just because
i'm i'm coming into breeding insight
well gdr is on its way to being grappy
compliant as well so we don't have to
have them changing they can still use
their database of choice because we can
connect to anything else through grappy
it's an incredibly powerful tool that
also extends to the breeding management
software that was put out by uh
integrated breeding platform
so this really allows
our
technology solutions to be used much
more broadly than just the users that
we're serving today
but we do a lot more than just work with
software
we work with we build genetic marker
sets two of our applications or our
programs already had
markers available either 2k or 50k snips
but we did help fund
extensive genotyping in those programs
and in the case of grapes we genotyped
over 7000
vines in the public repository
we've also created marker sets for
alfalfa blueberry and salmon within bi
and we're in the process of developing
markers for sweet potato and an endemic
weevil that is uh predating uh predates
on the sweet potato
so great once you have markers that's
great but you still need to have a
vendor who's going to keep costs down
for you you have a small program you
can't afford to be spending you know
thirty thousand dollars on genotyping so
we worked with the excellence in
breeding platforms module three to um
feed into their uh vendor pipeline which
starts with intertext for dna extraction
and uses the diversity array
technologies in australia for genotyping
and by working with them right now we're
at a pro cost point of between 10 or 11
depending on how many samples and that
includes dna extraction so that's a huge
benefit to our breeders
and we're hoping that with more volume
coming into these providers we'll be
able to call get that cost to come down
even further
so you've got markers you've got a
vendor
oh my genome's too big i can't use
markers like it's just too complicated i
don't know how to deal with it well this
is this is a real issue when you're
dealing with high polyploidy or auto
polyploids and we have those in our
program so
in collaboration with marcelo molinari
we've been working with our tetraploid
blueberry and i wanted to share
um some preliminary data from our work
with him so this is a preliminary map
not using haplotypes the data sets that
we are getting actually produce 54 base
pair amplicons so there's a target snip
and then there's off target snips that
we see so we get a lot of haplotypes per
locus so while we say 3 000 markers
we're actually seeing 3 000 loci so we
can get upwards of 8 000 markers coming
out of this system so it's kind of a
cross between
snip markers and ssrs where you're not
dealing in a binary situation
and this has allowed us to actually
separate by sub genome so here's our
genetic map on 200 draper by joule
by parental
f1
and
one thing that's been really exciting is
that we can now look at the genetic math
distance in comparison to the genomic
distance and i'm going to highlight some
regions where we genetically are not
seeing a lot of separation but we are in
the genomic space because those are the
centromeres
so we have enough uh coverage here to
actually identify where our
recombination space is and that's
extremely important if you're migrating
alleles and monitoring those alleles
through through breeding is to be able
to track
how much you're moving in and how big
the the
area around the trade of interest is in
drag
we're also helping integrate phenomx
tools in the field
there's a handheld app as i mentioned
field book that's being used in
vineyards and orchards and also in
fields
to
collect data
on
vines and plots and trials
and this is an android tablet app again
you have go out to the field with your
traits pre-loaded in your field
preloaded you can collect photographs
right on it there's also free text notes
and it has a barcode scanner so it kind
of has everything you need once you've
set it up in your field
and we're also testing a hands-free
voice to text option um with ag voice
and this take it just needs a smartphone
or a tablet a headset and a bluetooth
ring and you just touch the ring when
you want to turn on the voice and you
say your trait and value and then turn
it off and it collects it and spits it
out in excel
we're also integrating sonomic tools in
the lab
so here's an example from sweet potato
we're doing 3d imaging and with the
plant spec
uh plant eye plant phenol specs plant
eye
and he's using this specifically because
he wants to detect the percentage of
insect damage on the tubers that he's
harvesting but in addition to doing this
you can get a bunch of other phenotypes
as well length width volume area tuber
grade and counts all within one image
we're also
using fruit quality testing in blueberry
using penetrometer so this is an
instrument that outputs an excel file
for every session you have 30 berries go
into the tray you can get fruit firmness
diameter weight and berry scar size all
from a really fast measurement
and then we're also doing juice testing
in blueberry on express juice for a
number of different
components in that juice
and
we've also had some of our breeders say
i need to put some barcodes on my
locations or fixed objects and this is
really important if you're working in
salmon where you have tanks of in fish
and each tank is a family
and they move as they graduate from from
one size fish to the next size fish they
have to be moved physically so by fixing
a label
we could actually label tanks with a
very cheap and easy way to collect
animal welfare data which i'm not going
to talk about today because you guys are
horticulture people but it's really
important to keep track of your animals
when you're working with an animal
breeding program
so here's a simple method that we
developed to design the labels in field
are in breed base
laminate the page cut and trim those
labels get a half a coins velcro sticker
set and just put the stickers right on
the back and you can move them around
and they're waterproof and you can use
this to label storage bins for harvest
or
um storage shelves and rooms greenhouses
and benches within and also instruments
and equipment so if you have more than
one type of equipment you can actually
say which machine is this coming off
and this whole total cost was 100 bucks
so this is a really affordable way for
someone who
doesn't have a lot of money or doesn't
can't buy a brady printer and start
using barcodes in their program
so right now we're just finishing our
pilot phase and what that really means
is that
are breeding inside cores at ithaca and
we work across three
buckets of group of species so we have
specialty crops we're only working with
three out of approximately 50 the usda
breeds for
specialty animals we're only working
with two out of the approximately 15
and for natural resources just one out
of approximately 30 and we uh work very
closely with the national program the
office of national programs and tim
reinhart is our liaison for that and
this is the current model for our pilot
but we are now moving out of the pilot
into our next stage which would be
one breeding insight and the way this
works is that
this remains the same but now we can
distribute breeding inside coordinators
nationally by using a new program called
bi on-ramp i'll just spend a few minutes
talking about that
so bi onramp was originally created to
be an ars jumpstart readiness program
but it's actually expanded a little bit
beyond that
so
in terms of who it's for it's for any
non-specialty crop or animal breeders
that want to take on new technology but
don't qualify because they're not
specialty crops
but it also serves specialty crop and
animal breeders that want or need a more
extended transition if they're not ready
to just jump in and start making markers
and using technology this is a great way
for them to get their program ready to
go and it takes a one to two year
commitment
and for this second category they would
come into breeding insight and have the
rest of the
services filled out
and together with bi and bi on-ramp we
can help more breeders because we have
separate species
and we work very closely with each other
we share the same project management
solutions we're on calls with each other
we talk every week
and we have a lot of the same space that
we're working in um similar use cases
and data curation creating how-to's for
people this is
an area where we don't need to repeat
the same work we can share across both
programs
and as i mentioned we're coming into our
second phase and we've got our new
species coming in for tree fruits and
nuts it's cranberry pecan and strawberry
our animal forage and field will be oat
and honeybee
and for vegetables it'll be cucumber and
lettuce
and bi on ramp is picking up citrus
sugar cane soybean and cotton so these
two obviously are not specialty crops so
they would not fall under our model but
sugar cane and citrus could
so we or offer a lot of different
services and some of the services have
to come in order and we work with our
breeders to understand that but the
priorities and needs are really
determined by the breeder we don't tell
them so much as guide them to help them
build the scope that they are
comfortable with
and
the central model here is that you have
technology coming out of basic research
and it should just kind of trickle down
to plant and animal breeders
but breeding insights really here as a
conduit to help facilitate that transfer
from
basic science to applied science
and we work with our breeders to make
sure we have solutions that really do
fit for them long term not just today
and or you know this week in a testing
fee
and before i go i want to leave you with
one quote
and this is from liberty high bailey i
love this quote um
it's is there any progress in
horticulture if not it's dead it's
uninspiring
we cannot live in the past good as it is
we must draw our inspiration from the
future and i think that is exactly what
we need to be doing with our
horticultural crops we can ask more
of them than we do
and with that i'll take any questions
are there any questions oh wait
so mara i
you used the word
long term and when i was thinking that
listening to you i was
my question was so this is a usda
initiative like what is the long term
plan for that i mean like to be honest
if i was
a breeder my thought would be okay well
sure i can
get invested into that and it's not just
a question of money
[Music]
you know after the
i don't know two three years uh the
support is gone and ten years from now i
have an obsolete product so i'm back to
square one way better exactly no we hear
that a lot in fact we've gotten uh
several of them they're like i'm good
where i am i don't want your help
and you know we work around them
but the ars has really done a lot at the
area and
research level to make breeding insight
a priority that all the areas are
putting into their five-year plan so the
ars is just is making
investments into ars outside of what
breeding insight is doing here they're
making uh it a priority in research
groups and so the long-term model hasn't
been decided and it's above my pay grade
anyways but i know that um for now what
i keep telling them is that what we are
teaching you to do is how to do it for
yourself
you if you start using genotypes in your
program routinely you'll be able to know
exactly how much to budget for that how
much to put in and with a user interface
that's very breeder friendly
we should only have to be helping out
with like major problems or if there's a
new update that kind of breaks something
important but the idea is to to help
them get on the bike and then let them
ride the bike themselves but you have to
provide the parts for you know if you
buy the bike you want the money yeah
year round
to buy pods right
well i hope we'll be around to provide
spare parts for for a long time so the
good answer to my question is
usda isn't working yes
yeah um maybe jean-luc has more
information than i do
but i would disagree with your model
for your mom because the green level
that spans a lot of years a lot of
administrations
and
it's a huge game changer now
for
everybody for everybody
who's uh has
jumped on the banks and others so no i
mean i do not disagree with me like i
i'm not negative i say so for that to
have impact it has to be more than just
one job
for sure yeah because that's that was my
the point of my question
and i don't have an answer yet that
would satisfy your question
the answer is what's happening it's
happening it's happening but that was an
answer right
um i'm curious about uh adapting new
phenomics pipelines
into the existing system is that pretty
involved or can you like as long as a
federal pipeline has an output file
if if you're working with instrument
data that has an output file that's
super easy
um if you're working with something
where you haven't automated it like
let's say you're taking
pictures of
vine architecture and then having to
kind of draw
and simplify the picture down to extract
phenotypes if you don't have that
automated it takes a long time to do it
um it's it's cheap but it's labor
intensive but as soon as you can get
if you can automate that process like an
image j and then pull that information
out then any of that can be easily
imported into the uh breed base
or
we can find a way for braby to do it
directly
do you have a question
yeah so this platform like just
available it's like the species you
talked about or like other
people are interested in using it is it
like available for them to use that's a
fantastic question so right now it's
the funding comes from ars for ars so we
focus on that but
if there are public breeders that work
closely with our ars breeders they
benefit because the breeders told us i
can't run my program without nc state
doing the field trials so in that case
we'd support them as well
but once it's done i mean it's available
anybody can use it right now i should
have showed my my last slide with my
acknowledgements
there is a github site so anybody can
download and set this up for themselves
it's in a docker
it should have it should be easy to
deploy with you know some
with some help but
um but you could you could find um
you other people are absolutely welcome
to use it because it's all free software
i'm gonna get this thing off here so
people can
yeah maybe time for one more question
another second question
so why are you also thinking about like
like helping so from time to time like
we're kind of major developments in like
potential
breeding
developing new breeding programs like
let's say
diploid potato but the barrier to entry
for for breeder is huge is that
something that you
also thinking in involving in your like
overall scope of interest
i think so i mean if if we start working
with potato and they say well we want to
run
we run a tetraploid breeding program but
we also want to start setting up a
diploid breeding program we would help
them with that we would treat those as
separate programs that maybe one is
considered almost like a pre-breeding
program because eventually to be
commercialized you'd still have to be
tetraploid so
we could probably set up something very
simple and it wouldn't take a lot more
work for us to help them with that i
mean like it would be a like you would
have to start developing resources some
resources from scratch right
some but since most of the re i mean
there's already a marker panel for
tetraploid potato that works exactly
like our panel and it's able to work
with auto polyploids which
we'll see if it works with hexaploids
but it's so far for tetraploids
it looks easy
so
so deploys would be easy it's just that
um when you're taking a diploid and then
extracting or doing genomic selection to
try to anticipate what it's going to
look like as it is a tetraploid that's
you're discounting the fact that there
could be somatic mutations there too and
that's that's really why a lot of people
don't do that is because there's too
much unknown and they can't control for
it
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu